todd bowles buccaneers defensive
coordinator getting ready
for the title defense and peter
providing motivation to the buccaneers
the kings of the mountain are not the
kings of the peter king power ranking
mountain there they are at number two
behind the kansas city chiefs the full
top 16
intriguing you making them nervous in
cleveland peter putting the browns at
number four i was on radio there this
week and they they don't want that they
don't want that mantle hey get used to
it if you're going to be good people are
going to realize it and they're gonna
rank you accordingly but give me the the
uh
the explanation the reasoning why the
bucks with all starters back on both
sides of the ball with tom brady being
tom brady why are they at number two
behind the chiefs
because i think that the super bowl uh
was obviously the culmination of an
absolutely great run for the buccaneers
but
as much as we all want to say oh my god
they they've got everybody back
you know is that that's never happened
before is that a good thing how do we
know
i mean
how do we know that that is the best way
to do it do you want to do that if
you're jason light should you have done
that almost certainly yes
but what effect does it have on team
chemistry when your locker room is
pretty much exactly the same as it just
was because that's the way this team is
going to be
secondarily
i just think when i think about that
super bowl game
and i think of patrick mahomes
getting hit sacked and pressured 29
times
in that game never having a moment's
piece
in the pocket or even out of the pocket
last year in that super bowl when i
think of that i say what happens if
instead of having the 32nd best
offensive line in the nfl that day
what happened if they had the 12th
which i don't know what their number is
right now
but they have replaced four of the five
starters from the super bowl
and i think they're going to be
significantly upgraded on the offensive
line so
would that have been a whatever it was
31 to 9 game
if you know if the kansas city chiefs
had even a representative offensive line
in the game
it wouldn't have been a 22 point game i
can tell you that much
but look
we're all looking for something at this
time of year mike to say hey listen
here's how i projected here's what i
think
here are the teams that i think could
rise
and i mean that's why
i take a char an la chargers team and i
put them at 10. i see an awful lot of
things that i like in the chargers right
now that's why i put the browns for the
for the first time since i've been
covering
uh well since i've been covering the
league all right say in about 1989 i
look at the browns and i don't see a
glaring weakness that's never happened
before
and that's why i put them so high in
these rankings so i don't know you try
to make guesses
and you try to make projections
so that's all they are and it gets
people mad on twitter for a couple of
days and then everybody forgets it
let me put a pin in the browns
discussion for a second because you made
me think of something with the chiefs
and the buccaneers first of all
and i vaguely recall having this
conversation before about the value of
bringing back all of the starters i'm a
believer that when you've won a super
bowl there is benefit in bringing in a
veteran who's been around who's never
won one and that can help shake off the
complacency that sets in when he got a
bunch of guys who just climbed the top
of a mountain they got to do the
extended victory lap and now you're
asking them to climb the same mountain
again with all other teams targeting
them even more aggressively i think tom
brady's the difference here though he is
so driven now to get to number eight and
then he'll be driven to get to number
nine and he is just so
over the top competitive
pushing the buttons of all of his
teammates that that i think that they
won't fall into that trap
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports